-Last night
I went out to dinner.
You were also at the restaurant.
It was lovely
to see you beforehand.
-It was good to see you.
Except, you know,
I was wearing a lovely outfit.
I had a blue blazer,
a white shirt and khaki pants,
and so were the waiters --
exactly the same.
-Yeah.
-So when I went to the toilet,
someone asked me
for their oysters.
I was like, "Dude."
[ Laughter ]
-I was -- 'cause when I saw you,
you looked great in clothes.
I saw your outfit, I go, "Man,
Idris has got it figured out."
And then I walked in the
restaurant and realized,
"Oh, Idris has a problem."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Idris is about to find out
he has a problem.
You were very nice, as well.
You asked about my mother.
-Hillary.
-Yeah, my mom Hillary.
-How is she?
-She's great.
You met her a few years ago
at a party in L.A.
-Yep.
-She was a huge fan of yours.
You were very kind to her.
-She told you about that?
-She did tell me about that,
yeah.
She told my dad, too.
She pretty much brings you up
to my dad every day.
[ Laughter ]
His name is Larry.
Since she met you,
she calls him "Not Idris."
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Oh! Larry, Larry.
That's not nice. Sorry, Larry.
-But here, I want you
to know something,
because she's a huge fan of
yours.
But there's an opening right now
for you, because the top --
You're not the top.
The top is always, for my mom,
Daniel Day-Lewis.
-Who?
-Daniel Day-Lewis.
-I'm just joking.
-Wonderful actor.
-Yeah, I know, very good.
-You should definitely look at
his work.
But you know, now he's saying
he might get out of the game.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Yes! No!
-Exactly.
-But I'm just saying,
if you keep up
your high quality of work,
I feel like you could hit
that new pinnacle for my mom.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Again? Just joking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no, no.
No, no, no. This is awkward.
-It's great. No, like six hours
from now, when this airs,
the roof of our home,
my childhood home,
is gonna blow off.
[ Laughter ]
-Larry's like, "Who?"
-"Why?!"
Congratulations on this film.
This is a series of eight books,
the "Dark Tower" books.
This is the first one.
Are you a fan of this sort of
fantasy/horror genre?
-You know what?
I'm a fan of Stephen King.
I think he's an incredible
author. Right? He's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's a little dark.
-Yeah, he's a little dark.
This one's particularly dark.
-But "The Shining" --
I was a fan of "The Shining."
And also Jack Nicholson.
But, you know, I wanted to be
in a blockbuster.
I wanted to play a big hero
in a film.
And who better than Stephen King
to be the author of that?
-And it was interesting.
I read an article where
Ron Howard, as a producer, said
that when they were casting it,
the character -- Stephen King
wrote the character
to be sort of the biggest badass
in the world.
And when they started saying,
"Who currently
is the biggest badass?"
They said you came up
right away. That's high praise.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thanks.
But, no, they cast me because
Stephen King actually wanted
Clint Eastwood.
-Yeah.
-And said, "Who looks like
Clint Eastwood?"
[ Laughter ]
-Blatantly me, so that's how
that worked out.
-Yeah.
That worked out great,
and I should point out --
it wasn't in the clip,
but the villain in this film,
the wonderful
Matthew McConaughey.
-Yes.
-I feel like that's a good --
You guys are
a good yin and yang.
-Matthew's great. And he's
really good in the film.
He's very different.
He's very stoic, evil guy.
-Yeah.
-In real life.
Just joking, Matt.
But no, in the film,
he's really good. He's great.
-That's great.
Was this one of those action
films where you have to do
a lot of training,
and a lot of figuring out
how to play the part?
-Yeah, 'cause we wanted --
The film is quite grounded.
"The Dark Tower"
is quite grounded.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it looked like a normal,
everyday thing, yeah.
-But no, the director,
Nik Arcel, wanted us to --
at least the gunslinging,
all the shooting and stuff.
Six-shooting is a sport.
Reloading and shooting
on target,
so that's where
I started my training.
And we wanted to make that look
as real as possible.
-Great.
Did you get to be okay at it?
-I'm great at it.
-Oh, okay.
You didn't have to jump all
the way to great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, but -- I had an amazing
time making that film.
We shot it in South Africa,
which has some of the most
beautiful landscapes
in the world,
in the eastern cape.
And then we shot in L.A.
as well.
-And this is very exciting --
We were talking last night.
You directed your first film?
-Yeah.
-And so this is based on a book
called "Yardie" from the '80s?
Is that when it was written?
-Yeah, so it's a novel
from the '80s
which follows a young Jamaican
boy that ends up in London
and becomes a gangster,
and he's not really a gangster.
And I chose that film
because England has
a big Jamaican community.
I'm West African, but
the Jamaican community sort of
is the overriding influential
black community.
So I felt very connected
to the story,
and I wanted to see it happen,
and I loved it.
It was probably the best
experience as a filmmaker,
as an actor, to direct a film
because you're talking to
every single department about
so many different levels,
It was wicked. It was great.
-As a director, did you then
look back and say,
"Oh, Idris the actor had been
unfair to directors"?
-Oh, completely.
-Really? Yeah.
-No, seriously.
And the worst people
I hated on my set was actors.
-Yeah.
-Divas.
-What? Get here on time.
What, you don't know your lines?
Get out of here!
[ Laughter ]
No, but I had a great time
being able
to speak the language of acting
but not be on camera.
-That's really exciting.
And now, we've also talked
about this.
You're also a deejay.
-Yep.
-Because you have to be good
at everything
and make the rest of us
feel bad.
Oh, you're a six-shooter
and a deejay
and my mom's favorite person.
No, it's great.
-Kind of like your stepdad.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I'm sorry, Dad.
I shouldn't have brought it up.
-You set that up.
-That would be awesome, though.
[ Laughter ]
I would love, just like --
I mean, it wouldn't be a lot.
Just like one weekend a month?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-And you've done some
soundtracks of films before?
-Yeah, I did --
so, for "Luther," my TV show,
I made a soundtrack for that.
And basically what I do is take
the themes of the show
and work with musicians
and make original songs.
I did one for "Luther,"
did one for "Mandela,"
and I'm going to do one
for "Yardie" as well.